This is the shark tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
So how many
have you been selling?
I've sold about $2,500 worth.
You've sold dozens of them.
The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark to invest
the full amount
they're asking for...
come on, Mr. Cuban.
(chuckles)
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
I think I'm coming down
with a fever
'cause I just saw a dog go by
with a bow tie on. (chuckles)
(Robert laughs)
Oh, my God.
I love the dog.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest,
using their own money.
$1 million for 30%.
I forbid you to proceed.
And they're willing to fight
each other
for a piece of the action.
Okay, I'm gonna make you
an offer.
Would you let me
go in with you?
No.
I don't--I don't want
to work with the other sharks.
Mark's not giving you enough
anyways.
Mark's not done talking yet.
Oh... (laughs)
♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
Who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of QVC,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪
I'm Lakesha.
I'm Nzinga.
And I'm Tanecia.
(all) and we're from
Hampton, Virginia.
(Lakesha)
We're basically sisters.
We're best friends
attached at the hip.
Looks like we're ready.
We've been event planners
for over ten years.
We were looking for something
simple and versatile
that we could add to recipes
that would give our events
a unique taste.
So good.
I think this is gonna be
the best batch ever.
We put our heads together,
and the results were incredible.
A little more vanilla.
A lot of people think that Only
chefs can make a gourmet meal,
but our product
makes everyone a chef
because everything it's added to
tastes amazing.
Mm-hmm.
This business holds
a special place in my heart.
We started this business
when my husband was deployed
in Afghanistan.
It was very challenging,
but also a blessing
because it gave me a distraction
while I was raising
my daughter on my own.
So I feel like we both served
our country in a special way.
We need the sharks
to help us grow our business,
and we're ready to be
nationwide.
The sharks are gonna love
our product.
It's a guarantee.
It's shark bait, baby.
♪♪
(all) Hi, sharks.
I'm Lakesha.
I'm Nzinga.
And I'm Tanecia.
And our business is mango...
mango...
(all) Preserves.
We're asking for $75,000
for a 20% investment share
in our company.
We have a gourmet preserve
called "Mango mango."
We call it
"a party in a jar,"
'cause you can use it
over a hundred ways.
(all, singsongy) Spread it,
mix it, shake it, stir it!
Spread it, mix it,
shake it, stir it.
(laughs)
Spread it...
spread it...
(Lakesha) on toast, bagels,
or even croissants.
Mix it...
mix it...
mix it with cream cheese
for a delicious fruit dip.
Shake it...
shake it...
shake it with red wine vinegar
and olive oil
for a mango-licious vinaigrette.
(singsongy) Stir it...
stir it with Ginger shrimp.
(Tanecia) We've prepared
some samples for you to taste.
So, sharks, are you ready
to...
(all, singsongy) spread it,
mix it, shake it, stir it?
(Nzinga) Come on.
Spread it, mix it,
shake it, stir it.
Spread it... come on, Lori.
Spread it, mix it,
shake it, stir it.
What you'll be tasting today
is our mango fruit dip.
(Robert) Thank you.
In the martini glass,
there's some mango lemonade.
And then we have
the mango Ginger shrimp.
It's got a little kick
to it, so...
(Kevin) Let me help you there.
This is delicious.
This drink is made out of
the mango jelly?
(Lakesha) Yes.
We sweetened the lemonade
with our mango preserves.
Lakesha, this shrimp
is fantastic.
Thank you so much.
Wow.
Did you just put that in with
the shrimp when you were--
That's it. Just the shrimp
and the spice. And...
wow.
And the mango preserve.
Oh, try this.
I know. It's really, really,
really good. (chuckles)
I'm going to make
the assumption
that there's lots and lots
of other people
making mango mango mango.
There are a lot of people
making jellies and jams,
but no one is working
their jelly like us.
So you're working the jelly...
we're working the jelly.
And the other guys
aren't working the jelly?
They're not working it
like us.
You work it.
We're doing eight
farmers markets a week.
We're doing shows.
We're doing expos.
Okay, if you're working
the jelly so hard,
what are the sales?
Total year-to-date,
we've made about $138,000.
That's not bad.
(Lori) How long have you
been in business?
About a year and a half.
How are you selling it?
We're selling it
in natural food stores.
We're also selling it in a lot
of specialty and gourmet stores.
What do you sell this for?
We sell it to them
at $3.96.
And they sell it for $6.99.
What's your cost?
Two dollars and--
$2.18.
(Daymond) hmm.
(Kevin) That's high.
Why is it so expensive?
It's mango.
It's a tropical fruit.
What do you need the money for?
We need the money
for our production facility.
We want to take
an existing structure
and purchase the equipment
necessary.
Why don't you farm that out?
Why do you want
to do that yourself?
I think he's referring
to, like, a co-packer.
You would have them
make it instead.
Right.
Ship it, take care of
all of that.
We--we actually do--
We have so much pride
in our product.
We like to be able
to be h-hands-on.
(Kevin) I understand the pride,
but these numbers are not
a good long-term story.
I used to own a company
that made jams and Jellies.
Uh-huh.
And we used to take
our extra capacity...
(laughs)
And we--We'd farm it out
to anybody that wanted it.
(chuckles) is that true?
Not to demean the product,
but frankly,
if you tell us
what your recipe is,
we'll make it for you.
At what point in your life
did you own a jelly and...
(chuckles) Ja--Jam company?
(Lori laughs)
It's true.
Such an evil guy
making jellies and jams.
Yes, I am.
Lakesha, it's a great product.
Tell me about your background.
I'm actually
a military spouse.
We own
an event planning company.
And the other ladies?
I'm actually a physician.
Wow.
I'm a registered nurse.
(Kevin) Listen, ladies,
you have to get the cost
of this down--
To be like everybody else
in the jelly and jam business--
to $1.20.
How are you gonna do that?
(women chuckling)
(Lori laughs)
Robert liked that so little,
that he just took this
small glass full.
What you don't eat, Robert,
I'll take.
That's right.
(Kevin) If--if you looked at
anybody else in your business,
their cost would be at $1.25.
I think owning our own
production facility
is the key to that.
Hey, Lakesha,
what am I eating?
'cause it's like a drug.
(Lori) It's cream cheese.
I cannot stop.
(Lakesha) Yes,
it's cream cheese.
It's cream cheese, right?
Just cream cheese
and the mango mango, that's it.
No other jam or jelly
is gonna taste like that
mixed with cream cheese.
And what are
your projected sales
for this next coming year?
$291,000.
Are you selling it in
any of the military?
(Lakesha) Yes.
We're actually getting ready
to go into
the military commissaries.
(Robert) How big an order
would that be?
Uh, huge. We're--
Uh, that--
So would you go into
all of their stores?
'cause that's a big business.
We will. We will go into
all their stores.
Actually--
(chuckles)
He's eating mine now.
(mark) Robert,
pass that down.
(laughter)
That could be
a very big market.
Pass the cream cheese down,
Robert. Pass the cream cheese.
(speaks indistinctly)
Oh, my God.
Guys, you--You can't make any
money with this model.
Because you can't bring
a distributor into your model.
When you get bigger,
and all of a sudden
you've got a thousand stores,
the problem is
you can't make any money
'cause you've got to give
a distributor a dollar
on each one.
(mark) What comes after
mangoes?
It's all mango.
It's gonna be mango vinaigrette,
we're gonna--
Why aren't you going
into mango chutney?
It's a bigger category
than all of this.
Because you can use
our preserve...
(all) to make a chutney.
Man, you guys know
your mangoes.
(Lakesha) We--
Yes, from sweet to savory
to spicy.
(Kevin) You want to provide
the base.
And you need your product
to make all those
delicious recipes.
(Lakesha) That's right.
Right, right, right.
This stuff is...
Pretty damn good.
(Robert) Just keep talking.
I'm taking bets to see
if I can finish it
by the time you all
are done.
Yes.
(women laugh)
Lakesha, I'm not here.
Just ignore me.
Okay. Okay.
You know, I just have to say
it's a huge testament
because the two sharks
that right now
are watching their weight,
not eating a lot of carbs,
are Mark and Robert.
(mark) It's cream cheese.
(speaks indistinctly)
I used to watch my weight.
That cream cheese can make you
a lot of money.
(Robert) Lakesha, what's your
biggest challenge so far
with the business?
Because it sounds like
you're having a lot of success.
The challenge is production,
keeping up with demand--
Being on someone else's
schedule.
You can't get that money
anywhere else?
We--We could get the money
somewhere else.
We--we could.
But we would like to...
party with Sharks.
Yeah, we would like to party
with the--with the sharks.
We don't want you all to--
Hey, there's nothing like
a shark party.
(laughs)
(laughs) We want the party.
Yeah, we don't want you all
to do all the work.
We want to do the work.
We know the mango.
Guys, I have no doubt
in my mind
you are gonna be the world's
first mango millionaires.
But I don't know a chutney
from a shputney
from a potato.
But you know money.
I know money,
but it's just not my thing.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
Keep on jammin'.
(all, singsongy) Spread it,
mix it, shake it, stir it.
Spread it, mix it,
shake it, stir it.
I love you guys. (chuckles)
You know, you've created
a hobby here.
That's what it is.
It's not a business yet.
You are going to find out
the hard way
unless you take out 75 cents
out of your cost,
you're going to zero.
There's a lot of mistakes
in what you're doing.
I actually don't want
to educate you on this
'cause it's not
the "advice" tank.
Sorry to give you
the bad news, but I'm out.
You guys are great.
Thank you.
And I don't like mango.
But I loved everything
that was on my plate.
And you saw what Robert
did with it.
I rarely say this.
I don't think it's good
for you to actually give away
equity to a shark,
and I'll tell you why.
I think you should
fund yourselves
with the money that comes in
and retain your equity.
And because that's
my very best advice,
I'm going to go out,
but I hope that
that's what you do
because I see huge success
for you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
(Daymond) We tend not to want
to give our counterparts
credit up here, but I found it
fascinating that
Kevin... (chuckles)
Had a jelly and jam business
a couple of years ago.
(laughs)
I'm a sweetheart.
(women laugh)
So I actually have
to follow the lead
of somebody that's been
in this business
and has brought up some
very valuable questions.
I don't think I can be of
service with you in this area.
I'm out.
(exhales deeply)
Well, I hated the presentation.
I hated the food.
(laughter)
We could tell.
I've never had a product on here
that I loved so much.
I mean, I love it,
I love it, I love it.
You guys are the real deal.
Um...
♪♪
I'm afraid I'd eat
all the profits.
(laughter)
Oh, I just--I...
(sighs) You know, I'm picturing
the four of us in a meeting
and you're asking me,
"Robert, should we do this?
Is this the right thing to do?"
I would be so afraid
to steer you
in the wrong direction.
I wish you all the best.
I'm...
I'm--I'm gonna
sit this one out.
And as I said, I'm glad
you didn't get a deal.
I want the three of you
to run it together
and not have to give up
your equity.
(Nzinga and Tanecia)
Thank you.
We appreciate you all.
Thank you so much.
Thank you. Bye-Bye.
Bye-Bye.
(singsongy) Spread it,
shake it, mix it...
(woman chuckle)
(singsongy) Spread it,
mix it, shake it, stir it!
You know what?
They're gonna make it.
Not with these numbers.
They'll figure it out.
That was a fabulous
experience.
Oh, my goodness.
It was so nice to know
that they loved our product.
Oh, my gosh.
And they believe in us.
They believe in us,
and we have to respect that.
Oh, my God.
(singsongy) shake it, stir it,
going to zero.
Shake it, stir...
(laughter)
(Lori) Oh, god.
♪♪
Next into the tank
is a silicon valley veteran
with an innovation
he hopes will save lives.
♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name
is Charles Michael Yim,
and I'm the Founder and C.E.O.
of Breathometer.
I'm asking for $250,000
for 10% equity stake
in my company.
So just imagine
you're at a dinner party
or maybe even a tailgate.
Better yet, we're at
a local bar with some friends
having some Champagne.
Would anyone care for a glass?
Yes, please.
(Lori) Sure.
(Robert chuckles) Yeah.
(chuckles)
Oh, I-I thought
you were joking.
(speaks indistinctly)
Take it, Lori.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Daymond doesn't like
Champagne, so I'll take his.
(chuckles)
I was told he does.
(Lori laughs)
Here you go.
Thank you.
It's Daymond's favorite drink.
(chuckles)
(clink)
Thank you, señor.
Thank you.
(Lori chuckles)
(Robert) Charles,
what should we toast to?
(clink)
Uh, pitching to the sharks.
(chuckles)
To you, Charles.
Thank you.
Sometimes it ends badly,
though.
(chuckles)
so you know how it goes.
You eat some food,
you have some drinks.
Before you know it,
the night's over,
and it's time to go home.
And the most important
question is,
"Are you safe to drive"?
And...
who would want to carry
one of these
bulky old breathalyzers
around?
So that's why I created...
Breathometer--
The world's first
smartphone breathalyzer.
It's so small,
it can fit in your pocket.
Let me show you
how it works.
You simply retract
the audio jack,
plug it into a smartphone.
(clicks)
Activate the app,
(blows air)
Within a matter of seconds,
You'll be able to know
what your breath
alcohol level is.
And better yet,
it can even tell you
how long it'll take
to sober up.
And if need be,
you can even hail a cab
with the push of a button.
So please join me
on this mission
to help people make
smarter and safer decisions
one breath at a time.
Thank you.
So is this
already on the market?
Are you selling it currently?
So we basically launched
in March
via an indiegogo campaign.
We sold 4,000 units
within 30 days.
We generated $140,000
in revenue.
Indiegogo is
a crowdfunding site. Right.
It's just like kickstarter,
correct.
What do you sell them for,
Charles?
$49.99.
Could we see it?
Yes.
(chuckles)
I thought that one of
the biggest issues
around these things--
When the first handheld units
came out--
was that you get arrested--
Or worse,
you harm somebody
because you're drunk--
And you relied on the device
to make your decision.
Isn't that a huge liability
to you?
First and foremost, there's no
replacement for good judgment.
And so the Breathometer device
basically promotes,
uh, making smarter
and safer decisions.
We provide
the instruction manual.
We clearly label disclaimers
throughout the app.
And as long as we do our part
and the due diligence
and we uphold our side,
we're in the clear.
Should I come up
and try this with you?
Uh, sure.
Feel free to come up.
Okay.
(Kevin)
And if she doesn't pass...
if I can't walk--
Hey, if she can
walk in those heels,
you already
have your answer.
So...
basically go ahead
and plug it
into the audio jack
of your smartphone.
Um, all you need to do--
Do is hit the start button.
Okay.
Go ahead and breathe
into this hole--
right there.
A little closer.
(blows air)
(chuckles)
You're at a .04 right now.
That would be legal.
Yeah, you're legal.
Does it tell you
if she has bad breath, too?
(Lori chuckles)
Uh, it's funny
as you mention that,
uh, there's an al-also another
sensor we're looking into.
It's for halitosis.
Oh, seriously?
And through--and seriously.
I'm starting to think of this
as more of a multifunction
breathalyzer.
So the next one we're
actually trying to focus on
is, uh, diabetes.
It's in clinical trials.
And it's obviously less
intrusive
than blood pricking, right?
Charles, how did you
develop it?
Are you a software guy?
Are you a hardware design guy?
So I used to code
back in the day.
I built and sold my last company
within 18 months.
So, essentially, I went straight
into developing Breathometer
as soon as I exited
my last company.
If you sold your last business,
and you did very Well,
why didn't you take
some of that money
and invest it in this?
I have. Uh, so I started off
with the first initial $50,000.
I've already raised
half a million dollars
in total from angels.
What are you gonna use
the money for?
Uh, strictly, uh,
manufacturing of the product.
Well, the good news for you
is that both in Europe
and Canada, Mexico, U.S.,
we're going to almost
a zero tolerance
on alcohol and driving.
Correct.
That's the trend.
I'm sure you've heard about
the federal safety board
in the United States
that's trying to push down--
They just lowered it.
From .08 to .05.
I'm--I'm a big fan
of the sensor business.
I've got a company--
Motionloft.
We're all about sensors.
(mouths words)
You know, I think that's
the future of technology.
Okay, I'm gonna make--
I'm gonna make you an offer.
All right. What I'd like to do
is offer you $500,000
for 20% of the company.
That's my offer.
Okay.
I'll give you a chance
to talk to other people
because I know you want to.
Any other sharks? (laughs)
Mark, would you let me
go in with you...
no.
And handle the retail end?
(chuckles)
No. This is not-- I'm not
worried about the retail.
That's just, like, a smidgen
versus the long-Term benefit.
I'll give you $250,000 for 15%.
And you wouldn't have
to lose that much equity then.
That's not bad. Okay.
It's much less diluted
than Mark's 20%.
Okay.
And not nearly as much cash.
So just to open up the--the--
the "Funding channel"
of communication,
so the whole idea
within the next 60 days
is to close a full
$1 million round
from the angels
back in silicon valley.
So what I'm proposing
is I'm more than willing
to open up the round
and potentially involve
more than just one shark
because I think there's
an incredible amount
of value here.
Why don't you let the sharks
do the whole round?
That's what I'm proposing.
(laughs)
I don't--I don't want
to work with the other sharks.
♪♪
You want to raise
a million dollars, don't you?
I do want to raise
a million dollars.
So Mark's not
giving you enough anyways.
Mark's not done talking yet.
Oh... (laughs)
(Robert) All right.
Here's what I'll do, Charles.
I'll give you another $250,000
if Kevin will have me on that.
I'll do it. That makes
a lot of sense to me.
And I'll give you
another $250,000.
For 30%.
Wow. Okay.
And they have no idea
what they're investing in.
That's not true.
It is absolutely true.
So you've got $750,000--
Three times what
you asked for today...
right.
For 30%.
Right.
You're very smart.
I like to surround myself
with people much smarter
than me.
That's why I have a challenge
being up here.
Thank you very much.
(chuckles)
Um...
I want to, uh,
I think I want to match
what you're offering.
$250,000,
unlimited manufacturing...
okay.
10%.
And you wouldn't want
to partake in the group's...
I've tried to get these
three bobos together
at breakfast one day and--
and--and it's hard, you know?
(laughter)
It's like, we--we don't need
all these people.
(Kevin)
Right now we can't agree.
We've got three, maybe one--
Well, I think we can agree,
Kevin.
What if we raised the dollar
amount we're putting in?
But wait--Wait,
I'm just saying for
a million bucks
of straight equity,
and get all the sharks in it.
Now I don't know if mark
wants to play ball,
but we need a significant
discount to do that.
You would be
an unbelievable story
if that happened.
That's true.
Mark, because of your
previous investments in sensors,
you need the lion's share.
Tell us what that is.
Because competing
with each other
is gonna be very expensive
versus colluding with each other
and giving this guy
every single shark.
Come on, Mr. Cuban.
(chuckles)
Daymond, you're--
You're in on this, aren't you?
I'm willing to go in
if Cuban's in,
and you'll get
all five sharks.
♪♪
Charles has the potential
of raising $1 million--
All the funding he needs
at this point--
if Mark will join the rest
of the sharks on a deal.
Daymond, you're--
You're in on this, aren't you?
I'm willing to go in
if Cuban's in,
and you'll get
all five sharks.
Come on, Mr. Cuban.
(chuckles)
You get the lion's share.
What does
"The Lion's share" mean?
What--what equity do I get?
So we--
to get all five sharks.
You need a million bucks
for that.
(Lori speaks indistinctly)
Now it's your turn--
now it's your turn to sell me.
(clears throat) Wow. Um...
what can you give us
on a straight equity deal?
This is your round right here.
Right now, the whole damn thing.
Wow, that's pretty serious.
Uh...
Oh, Charles, think.
You gotta come up
with a really good offer.
Okay.
♪♪
Would you be okay
with taking say 300--
Doing $300,000? They split up
the $700,000 amongst them?
I'll do--I'll do
500k for 15%.
For 15%?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
All five sharks will give you
a million dollars.
$500,000 for Mark Cuban for 15%
and $500,000 split
amongst the 4 of us
for the other 15%.
So $1 million for 30%.
Um... (chuckles)
(Kevin) Do it.
(Lori) do it.
(exhales deeply)
There's a reason
the Champagne's open, my friend.
Can I have a second
to make a phone call
To my C.F.O.?
Sure.
Yes, of course.
Okay, thank you. (sighs)
♪♪
Hey, Matt, how's it goin'?
Hey, Charles.
So they have basically,
uh, all have, uh,
provided an offer--
Um, all five of them.
And so basically
a million dollars,
uh, for 30%, uh,
of the company.
So I just wanna kinda
get your thoughts.
You know, a million for 30--
Um, 30%,
you know, that's
a $3.3 million valuation.
It's not a huge valuation.
Sure.
I mean, I--fundamentally,
I'm a little bit worried about
too many cooks in the kitchen.
I mean, they all have
big egos, um, and so,
you know, can they work together
effectively?
Who wants to bet
what he comes back at?
He'll come back at 25%.
I say 25%.
Yeah, you're right.
Well, let's see what happens.
He's been out there a long time.
(exhales deeply)
Charles, welcome back.
Thank you.
You have an opportunity
to get all five sharks
and the power
of all sharks behind you.
Right.
Here's the deal. $1 million--
$500,000 for Mark Cuban
for 15%, and $500,000...
(chuckles)
from the rest of the sharks.
We're gonna split it.
Right.
For a total of 30%
for $1 million
and the power of "Shark tank."
What are you gonna do?
♪♪
(sighs) I accept.
(applause)
All right!
(Lori) Whoo!
(laughter)
Wow.
That's great.
I gotta tell ya,
I didn't see that coming.
Thank you.
That's great.
Thank you very much.
(chuckles)
What made you
change your mind?
(Lori) We all should toast
to that.
Charles, have a toast with us.
(laughs)
All right. Cheers, guys.
(Robert) Cheers!
(clinks)
(all) cheers!
I've never thought about
raising all the cash
that we needed
from the entire team
of the sharks.
I'm ecstatic right now.
I have no words. (chuckles)
I'm shocked.
♪♪
Last season, teenage
entrepreneur Lani Lazzari
made a deal with Mark Cuban
for her skincare line
Simple Sugars.
I would love to accept
your offer.
That's what I like to hear.
(chuckles)
Let's see how she's doing now.
♪♪
Everything about my business
has changed
since coming out of the tank.
Simple Sugars.
Can I help you?
Prior to "Shark Tank,"
our sales were only $50,000.
In just the first 24 hours
following the show,
we had already reached
$220,000.
And six weeks later, we were at
a million dollars in sales.
When I pitched on "Shark Tank,"
we had
three part-time employees.
Now we've grown to a team
of 24 employees and 8 interns.
(cell phone rings)
Hello?
Hey, Lani, it's mark.
Hi, mark. How are you?
It's pretty cool
to have a billionaire
as a business partner.
I just want to say
congratulations
on a million dollars in sales.
When I partnered up with mark,
I was a little bit worried
that he was gonna treat me
just like a little kid.
But he's shown confidence
in my ability
to run this business,
and really treated me
like a true colleague.
I'm here to help.
And let's keep on kickin' butt.
Thank you so much.
I'm so excited.
Wow. It looks so good.
Whenever I walk into a store
and see my product,
it makes me feel awesome.
It's so exciting
to see it there.
I am so proud of you.
Thank you so much, mom.
One day, I hope to be
the best company in America
for women to work for.
As far as women have come
in the corporate world,
I think there's still
a long ways to go,
and I want to be the one
to make that change happen.
I'm living proof that
hard work and persistence
pay off in a big way.
Thank you, "Shark Tank."
(all) Hey, "Shark Tank,"
stay smooth. Whoo!
♪♪
Next up
is an entrepreneur
with a product to reward men
for their good deeds.
(chuckles)
Oh, please.
Stay in your seat, Lori.
It's about time.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Jim O'Brien.
My company is Man Medals,
and I'm asking for $10,000
for 10%.
Now, sharks,
I could stand here all day
and talk to you about
Man Medals,
but instead I want to show you
how I came up with the idea.
And to do that, I've brought in
my exact body double....
(laughter)
For a historically
accurate re-enactment
of how I came up with
the idea.
This started as
a running joke
between me
and my lovely wife Kathy.
Whether it was flexing
as I picked up my dirty laundry
to put it in the hamper...
(laughs)
(chuckles)
Or...
actually taking
the toilet paper Roll
and putting it
on the Holder,
which guys don't think
is a problem,
but women obviously do.
(laughter)
And those rare occasions when
you would take the toilet seat--
While apparently
sticking my butt out...
(laughter)
And lowering it.
Why is he looking at me?
(Lori) I don't know. (laughs)
Why are you looking at him?
Every time I did this,
my wife would always laugh
and say, "What do you want,
a medal"?
and I thought to myself...
yes... Yes, I do.
(laughter)
and that, sharks, is where
Man Medals came from.
There are six original
Man Medals.
(laughter continues)
I took the garbage out,
I picked my dirty clothes up,
I put the toilet paper roll on,
I put the toilet seat down,
I ran the vacuum cleaner,
and I asked for directions.
I've been selling these online
for less than a year.
And I'm not getting orders
from just in the United States.
I'm getting responses
from Canada, England,
Ireland, Norway, scotland,
and as far away
as australia, new zealand...
even India.
(laughter)
So, sharks, are you ready
to earn a medal?
Ah.
(Lori) Ah. (chuckles)
We get a lot
of bad theater in here,
but this was
pretty good bad theater.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
I want to give
your body double
an award for the sexiest look.
So can you raise your eyebrow
again like that?
(laughter)
Can I see you do the same?
Oh, yeah, there's
the body double, yeah.
(Lori laughs)
I have to say, though,
we're always getting girls in
in bikinis. It's about time.
It's a hilarious shtick.
So how many
have you been selling?
I've sold
about $2,500 worth.
(laughter)
A whole $2,500 worth?
I know. I know.
I thought you were selling them
all over the world.
Less than a year, you said?
Honestly, yeah.
$2,500 so far.
You've sold dozens of them.
600.
(laughter)
Hundreds.
I've sold hundreds.
These you see here
are the retail displays.
So all six of these pins--
what you're holding
in your hand
we've only had
for less than a month.
Jim, what do you charge
for them?
Retail is $5.
My cost is 65 cents
for that whole package.
We wholesale 'em
for $2.50,
which gives them a price point
for retail stores
anywhere between $5 and $6.
Have you done, Like, uh,
any type of trade show,
or like a, you know--
(chuckles) Trade shows?
That's the next step for me.
So go do a show
and see first,
is this something that's viable?
And then think about whether
or not you need an investment.
I hope you are successful,
but it won't be with me.
I'm out.
Thank you.
I think this idea merits
a full financial ex--
Exploration because
really here...
we're talking about
$10,000 for 10%--
a punitive value of $100,000.
Correct.
Now I look
at the public multiples
of medal companies like this...
(laughter)
So the valuation here
is really aggressive, I think,
I-I mean...
(laughter continues)
You know, there's two things,
though, Kevin,
in talking about that.
The first one is
I know
something about medals.
I spent nine years in the navy
before I got into this.
I earned a couple medals,
actually.
And I know men like medals.
You watch the Olympics,
you get medals.
The--
and the joke tells itself,
which is one of the things
I like that I did--
Jim...
men Like shiny objects.
I think it's a great start.
It's a cute idea.
I think you did
a great presentation today.
But as far as the medals
are concerned, I'm out.
If I'd have come to you
35 years ago
with a rock in a box
and said,
"I'm gonna sell
a million of these,"
you would have laughed at me.
That was before the internet
and before social media.
So with an item like this
that people are talking about--
and I know
it's in small quantities,
but I'm still getting
responses from people
from around the world--
but it's not a business.
I--all due respect,
I beg to disag--beg to--
I beg--
Oh, yeah, because
those $2,500 in Sales
really begs to differ.
Uh, again, this is something
that we're in the ground floor.
(laughter)
And you know what?
The problem is--The problem is
you're in the ground floor--
You're not in the ground floor,
and you're gonna stay
in the ground floor.
You're in the basement.
I'm out.
I forbid you to proceed.
Thank you.
Daymond?
I don't--I don't think
the $2,500 is a big problem.
I stood on a corner
and sold hats the first day
that I made with my hands,
and I made $800. That's it.
It takes as much energy to--
To dream small
as it does to dream big.
So...
but I didn't ask for
anybody's help at that point.
It's gimmicky. It just
isn't for me. I'm out.
Thank you, sharks.
Good luck, Jim.
Thank you.
Good luck.
That's the first...
that was the...
that was the funniest pitch.
Beefcake-y guy that's
come into the tank.
Barbara would have gone
bonkers.
(laughter)
♪♪
Next into the tank
is an entrepreneur
from New York City with
fashion forward accessories.
Oh, that's a real dog.
He looks scared.
No, he's fine.
(laughter)
He's so cute.
Hello, sharks.
This cute little guy
here with me
is my dog Kane,
and I am Amber Lee Forrester,
the founder and president
of Kane & Couture.
I am seeking
a $150,000 investment
for a 33% stake in my company.
Kane & Couture is
a canine lifestyle brand...
offering fashionable,
functional collars,
harnesses, leashes, carriers,
apparel, and useful accessories.
Puts the style in you
and your doggy's lifestyles.
(chuckles)
When I started Kane & Couture,
I found that most of the items
on the market
were plaid, plain,
or suburban.
Most of the unique items
were grossly overpriced
and hard to find.
Kane and Couture...
(snoring)
(laughter)
(Robert) Aw.
Isn't that cute?
He fell asleep.
You're Boring him, Amber.
You're Boring him.
Am I b--
Oh, I don't want him
to fall asleep.
That's how--
That's how comfortable he is.
(laughs)
Under the Kane & Couture
umbrella,
we have
our signature premium line
as well as our
value driven lines--
The Bubba dog collection
and imperial pup.
But, sharks, I'd rather
show you than tell you.
Meet Dina and Henry.
Henry is ready for
his day out on the town.
Aww...
look at--
(Lori) Aw.
(chuckles)
He's outfitted in our
boyfriend button-down shirt
and our easy and convenient
step-In one-piece
harness and Leash.
Henry is so embarrassed
right now.
He does. He looks very cute.
(chuckles)
Yeah.
And next, we have
Courtney and Solstice.
Oh, wow.
Solstice can get in touch
with her feminine side...
(kisses)
in our remi pink collar
and matching leash.
And Mr. Casey Kane
loves to travel in style.
He is riding in
one of our signature
Kane & Couture carriers.
They are designed
to look like purses.
But they're actually suited
for the comfortable travel
of your pet.
(laughter)
(Lori) Aw.
I really need
an amazing partner
to help me take this
to the next level.
So, sharks,
I'd like to discuss
how we can take a bite
into this industry together.
Can I see Kane?
Yeah.
Amber, you wouldn't really
take him out in public
like that, would you?
(Lori) Aw, he's so cute.
(high-pitched Voice) Hi, baby.
He--This is for
special occasions.
(Robert kisses
and Imitates dog whimpers)
if he's going to a wedding,
people love to take
their dogs places,
and they want
to dress them up.
(Kevin) Amber, how often does
Kane get invited to a wedding?
Every day.
Well, I mean,
I have had one
that he's come to
and worn a tuxedo. (chuckles)
and...
I have to come look.
(Robert laughs)
Amber, look,
before we get started,
can I ask you
a practical question?
Sure.
When you carry a small dog
around in a bag
for extended periods of time,
what happens if the dog
has to pee-pee or poo-poo?
(chuckles)
Then you let him out the bag
so he can pee-pee or poo-poo.
Well, does he tell you?
Does he tell you that
that's what he's planning?
Well, you know your dog.
And so you'll know his
pee-pee and poo-poo pattern.
Kevin, do you never--
Have ever had a pet?
(Kevin) Has---has--
Has Kane ever pee-peed
in a bag?
So he's 6 years old.
He's been trained.
America wants to know
what happens
when he's in the bag.
Oh, my.
So Kane is 6 years old.
Yeah.
He's been traveling
since he was 8 weeks old.
That's a 50-year-old dog
in dog years.
Uh, Yeah, yeah,
I mean, well--
and usually when you turn 50
you have to go more often.
You gotta go.
You get a little incontinent.
(laughs)
So I was just wondering...
so maybe my next invention
should be, like,
some doggy diaper
that's cute?
Well, no, we've seen that
already, thank you.
(laughs)
(Robert) Amber,
do you have sales?
My sales in the last year
were just about $90,000.
And how do you sell?
Through what? Retail?
Online?
Yes, so I sell through
retail and online.
(Daymond)
What are the major retailers?
Macy's carries my products
on a seasonal, um--
Really? Macy's?
Amber, what will
your sales be next year?
My projection in the next year
is $1.8 million.
From $90,000 to $1.8 million?
You're gonna get from--Huh?
Well, I have people
who are ready to order
starting the holiday
this year.
So I'm ready to get
very aggressive.
Wh--Amber, what does that mean,
"They're ready to order"?
I'm putting together
the packages that they like
in order to present them
to them.
Unfortunately, with coming here,
I wasn't able to do so before.
(Lori) So prices for
these things--
Like, I had picked up
this really cute collar.
Mm-hmm.
And it says, "Sparked."
Yes.
So what would this cost
you to make,
and then what do you sell it
to the retailer for,
and what do they sell it for?
Uh, about $3.
Right, and what are they
selling it for?
They're selling them from
anywhere from $20 to $24.
What's the difference
between your stuff
and the millions
of other products
that are out there like it?
Wait, let me answer.
Nothing.
No, that's not True,
actually.
Well, what is it?
So the difference is
it's a brand.
You also have--
but I don't know
the Kane & Couture brand.
Not at $90,000 a year in sales.
You have no brand.
Well, people are learning
our brand.
And I kind of feel like
I'm, like, the fubu for dogs.
Like... (chuckles)
(chuckles)
(laughter)
Great.
I'm okay with that.
It's true. There wasn't
a lot of really, like,
like, there was--It was
plaid, plain, or suburban.
I really mean that.
There weren't like, like,
how we have our
boyfriend button-downs and--
Boyfriend button-down for a dog.
Yes.
That dog has a bow tie on.
That's insane.
It's not to everyone,
just maybe to you.
It's crazy.
Do you have a dog?
No, thank goodness.
Amber, are you kidding?
I have children.
I don't need a dog.
(chuckles) Oh...
that is ridiculous.
How many years did you say
you've been in business?
So I've been in business
about four and a half years.
I've been full time with it
for three years.
Within that time,
I've gone to some classes.
I've also had a baby
and got married.
So it's been a full
four and a half years.
Sorry, Amber, maybe I missed
how you're going to go
from $90,000 to $1.8 million...
$1.8--
in one year.
Let me tell you.
'cause that would be
faster growth than Fubu.
Uh, well, let me tell you.
Absolutely.
And I-I even feel that that
could be somewhat conservative.
(laughs)
Because I'm already in front
of seven major retailers
who are ready to place orders.
Even if I just started
in 10% of their stores,
then I can get
to $1.8 million.
These major retailers--
You have hard copy orders?
I have--I will have
hard copy orders.
I don't have hard copy
orders today. I--
I'm in discussions with them.
And so...
and So, as you know--
I'm sorry, Amber, I'm not sure
what that means.
I-I've been in sales
for a long time.
Okay.
I know there's a lot of talk
before Somebody actually
gives you an order.
Yes.
Just like my sales guys
always come back and tell me.
Well, I've had orders
from them before.
It's not like I'm just saying
that I'm gonna get orders.
But, Amber, they can buy
dog crap from anybody.
(whimpers)
Well, I don't have dog crap.
I have very nice dog items.
I don't mean it in--
in a negative way.
Good for you.
I don't mean it
in a negative way.
Kevin.
You know what I mean.
You don't mean that
in a negative way?
Why would they be different than
anybody else's dog tchotchkes?
Well, why would your suit
be different from
anybody Else's suit?
Yeah, but...
name me one dog collar brand
outside of Kane & Couture.
Like, give me another
brand dog collar.
I would rather not.
But there isn't one.
Listen, I-I think--
I think I'm coming down
with a fever
'cause I just saw a dog
go by with a bow tie on.
(laughter)
I just--I'm sorry.
That gave you a fever?
I don't get it,
and I hope I'm dreaming.
But while I'm dreaming
in this nightmare,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Sorry, was he out?
Yes, he's out. Yes.
(laughter)
There it is again.
(laughs)
I love the dog.
See, he's Loving Kane
in his tuxedo.
Oh.
What would be
a sales projection
that you would
actually expect
for a company that's
at my level? Like, where--do--
Amber, I didn't have
a problem with projections.
I had a problem with
the way that you said
You were going to do it.
Okay.
For you to go from $90,000
to $1.8 million in 12 months
would be... unbelievable.
To go from where you are now
to that level of sales,
I mean, that just, uh, it--
It just lacks reality to me.
For that reason, I'm out.
(mark laughs)
Okay. Thank you.
(whispers) Come here.
That dog saw the bow tie
just now.
(laughter)
So I'm gonna make you an offer.
Whoa.
I think that this
can go somewhere. I really do.
But why? Why?
Because people love their pets.
Bottom line. But...
it's contingent on
Daymond going in with me.
(sighs)
I think that Daymond
can offer a lot
on the fashion and--
and distribution end as well.
I do, too.
So, Daymond...
I think I would like
to make her an offer...
(laughs)
$75,000/$75,000 for... 40%.
For what percentage?
Daymond, I think that
we could do--
Really help her to do
good things with this.
I am stunned, and I am
going to forbid them to do that.
You are being a hater
right now.
So, Daymond, you haven't
said anything yet.
Are you in with Lori?
♪♪
Two sharks are out.
Lori is interested,
but only if Daymond
will go in on her offer.
So, Daymond, you haven't
said anything yet.
Are you in with Lori?
(Lori) What would she need
to do, Daymond,
to make you feel that
this is appealing?
Well, you know...
I really got scared
when she said, you know, 1.8,
you know, $90,000 this year,
1.8 next year.
(Robert)
That's where you lost me.
I mean, it was
a great pitch until then.
Lori, you do understand
that she did $90,000
last year, right?
She said--
She's valuing the company at
about a half a million dollars.
But a part of the reason
that I only did--
This is a massive undertaking.
You understand that, right?
I do, except it can be simpler.
Maybe we take and focus on
her top Sellers--
We're gonna give her
$150,000 for that?
She got into Macy's.
That's not easy. Right?
One store.
It--It's a not easy
store to get into, though,
and you know it.
You have an offer.
Daymond has not spoken.
Mark may up the bid.
We don't know.
(laughter)
Mark, over to you.
I have no interest
in this business.
I'm out.
Okay, let--
Let me ask you something.
I'm gonna try to make
a decision here.
Okay.
So wh--
I just wanna make a point here,
as a financial investor.
If you do this deal...
(chuckles) You will make
hundreds of dollars.
(laughter)
I've made more than hundreds
of dollars on my own.
I'm sorry.
The dog has a bow tie on.
Even if you just made
$300,000,
then you've already made back
the investment that you put in
in the first year.
Okay, here you go.
All right, I'll give you--
Uh, but I'm gonna have
to give you a contingency.
For you to do $1.8 million,
how much do you think you need
to get in just opening orders?
So then that number
would probably be around
$400,000.
Okay.
Okay, so I will go in
with Lori on that deal,
half and half,
if you provide us with
opening orders of $400,000.
Okay.
For 40%.
So would you consider
helping me with
the financing of
the purchase orders
for those? Because that's
also a large undertaking...
Yes, I will. Yes.
For me.
(Lori) Yes. I--
'cause it's a lot for me
to do on my own.
That's why I'm here.
We understand that.
No, we understand--
We understand--
to simplify it...
it's not about the money
with us.
It's about the undertaking
of... educating you
with this entire process.
It's--It's a lot.
Do we have a deal?
You have a deal.
All right.
Oh!
Thank you.
There you go.
I will work
very, very hard.
(Daymond) Please do.
Thank you.
I believe in you.
Thank you so much.
That means so much.
I-I just--I'm in shock
as to what happened here.
Thanks, guys.
Amber, thank you.
(shrieks) Yay!
(chuckles)
(shrieks)
What did you see in her?
(Kevin)
Lori, she dresses dogs.
You know what? You are
judging her way too harshly.
Well, that's why I kept quiet.
I didn't want to be a hater.
What--what's this hater stuff?
The dog has a bow tie on.
You know what?
It's ridiculous.
Now I'm gonna prove you wrong.
You know me.
That was a lot of hard work.
And that was really intense.
(high-pitched voice)
You did it!
(exhales deeply)